The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART:
Anyway, I'd better
abbreviate all this stuff
that I want to cover today.
The next three classes
are going to cover
cases of very complex,
but very direct,
relationships between social
and spatial structure.
There is a literature
largely from the left side
of the market on these issues.
I don't have time to go
through much of this here.
You should read the
required reading
for this class,
Kevin Lynch's piece--
chapter on social and spatial
structure relationships.
On the left, I would
assume the argument--
that space is an active agent,
that it involves conflict,
that it's political--
and this is an argument that
is articulated very well
by Henri Lefebvre in the
translation of his writing
into English.
David Harvey's first book,
Social Justice In The City,
argues that, under capitalism,
investment will never
stream towards the poorer
sections of the society,
because capitalism has so
many circuits of investment.
An object of
capitalist investment
is always maximizing profit.
There are less
attractive writings
by Manuel Castells in his
pre-Berkeley stage, the book,
The Urban Question,
and so on, and so on.
There's David Gordon's
writing about the origins
of American suburbia as
being the result of labor
friction in the
central business area,
and the bosses wanting to move
as far away from the workers as
possible.
And there are many
histories of this kind.
Castells' piece,
The Wild City, which
argues that suburbia is a
form of advanced capitalist
investment in which you
have to create markets
for prolific domestic
goods, and suburbia
is an attractive avenue
for this kind of market.
His writing is
called The Wild City.
He claims the American
city wild in the sense
that it obeys the
consequences of market action
in a very obvious kind of way.
It's not hidden or transformed.
There's an enormous
amount of writing.
There's this writing and from
the center and the right.
In Sunday's New
York Times, there's
a piece called "Suburban
Disequilibrium."
I don't know if anybody
looks at these things.
It simply says that suburbs
are an equal, something
that one would presume to know.
And the reason suburbs
are unequal are given,
and they haven't changed--
and not much has changed.
She cites examples of
suburbs close together
in Los Angeles, where one
house sells for $68 million.
And a few miles away,
there's a suburb
of Mexican-American
workers who can barely
afford to buy their house.
In teaching this material,
I found over the years
that the material is very
much stretched to large ideas
about economic science
and social policy.
There's very little discussion
of the meaning of place.
Donald Appleyard has written
about that and some others--
what place means, what space
means to people, and so on.
So I've decided to
follow a different route
in dealing with this.
I've established a notion
called "bipolarity"
and chosen cases where the
conflict between various groups
in the city is very explicit
and under different conditions.
So we will examine Johannesburg
from its origins in 1876,
I think, to today, following a
path of explicit racial policy.
South Africa invented or
formalized racial policy
to an extent that no other
country and no other state
in the world ever has.
So we should look at
Johannesburg and what
this space of Johannesburg
looks like as a result
of the enforcement of absolute
inequities between White
and Black.
We should look at
the colonial city.
We look at Delhi and New Delhi.
We look at the border between
Mexico and the United States
and look at the polarity
between country and city
in the development of Havana.
Today's class is really
dealing with the mother
of all social complexities,
and that's Jerusalem.
I want to do a case
study on Jerusalem.
And just for those of you
who haven't read the required
reading for today--
which is a long piece which
I wrote after months of work,
and I'm so sad that
you haven't read it--
I'll go through the very--
let me just explain what
I've handed out to you.
After this, the
map of the history
of Jerusalem, a simplified
history, on the next page
is a drawing.
It's a drawing on a napkin
by the head of the planning
section of MOPIC, the
Palestinian organization
after the Oslo Accords, which
I worked with for a while.
This was the depiction of
the future of Jerusalem--
as one metropolitan area with
the Jewish sect on the West,
and the Palestinian
sect on the right,
and the historic
center in the middle.
Below that is a letter,
which is obvious,
pointing out the
stupidity of some
of the writing on this issue.
So what I'm going to
do is try to take you
through a history,
which starts off
as a history, for a
long time, a history
of religious consequence,
and transforms much later
and in recent times,
certainly in this century,
into a geopolitical conflict.
And we end up with
the status quo.
Let's follow this
map very briefly.
The origins of Jerusalem
are, again, political.
For Palestinians, it
talks about the Jebusites,
and the Canaanites, and
the origins of the city
prior to 1,000 BC,
which is the date
that the Davidian City, the City
of David, argues its beginning.
David captures Jerusalem,
according to this.
This is an Israeli map.
According to the
Israeli history,
David bought the threshing
fields on the Temple Mount
from the Jebusites for 15
shekels, the equivalent
amount of money.
And in order to unify the
spread out of Jewish tribes,
he built the first--
he was a lover, and a
poet, and a general,
and according to
strict Hebrew law,
was not able to build a temple.
So his son, Solomon, was the
author of the first temple.
I'll show you a
drawing, by Corbusier
of the tribal environment,
which the Jews, and most people,
established at the time.
And the drawing shows the temple
as the first physical presence
in a city.
Seeing that the religious
city for a long time
just depended on a
religious infrastructure,
it's clear that
the first temple--
this temple exists for about
500 years, during which time
the Middle East undergoes
sieges and invasions.
The most significant
invasion is by Nebuchadnezzar
in the 6th Century.
This has enormous
consequences historically,
and I tend to
exaggerate some of them.
Nebuchadnezzar came from
the world's greatest city
at the time, Babylon, the
most advanced city of all.
Instead of killing the Jews,
he took them back with him
as prisoners and allowed the
Jews to establish themselves
in Babylon in a
relatively free manner.
Why he did that, which
was very contrary
to social international behavior
at the time, I don't know.
What happened was
significant for the Jews.
Not having a temple,
not having priests,
you must understand
the organization
of the social structure
around the temple.
The temple was run by priests.
There was no
democracy in religion.
You took what the
priests gave you,
and the priests were monitors
of the Holy of the Holies.
If you look at the plans
putated for the first temple,
you will see that structure.
The Jews didn't have temples.
They either had to
give up their religion
or convert to some
other pagan religion.
Having been the first
monoethicists of all, having--
monotheism was
founded in Jerusalem.
Nobody quite knows how.
But the idea that many
gods were dysfunctional,
and that the single God,
an invisible single God,
was the proper course
for religious faith.
So the Jews prayed in
houses and in schools--
wherever they could.
This type substitution
was an extraordinary idea.
In the history of the
Church, I found a reference
to saying that this
was the beginning
of the idea of the
church free of the rule
of plutocratic priests.
People could indulge in
a critical examination
of their faith
together as a group.
In fact, the conflict
towards the end
of the Jewish reign in
Jerusalem at the time of Jesus
was very much a conflict
between the priests
of the Second Temple
and the Pharisees,
who were advocating--
beginning to advocate
the democratic religion
in the form of the synagogue.
So the synagogue emerges
in primitive form
in the exile of a Jewish
group from the temple.
There's a second
phenomenon which
occurs during this period.
In the Judeo-Christian
Bible, there
are seven chapters
devoted to Ezekiel.
Who was Ezekiel?
What role did he play in the--
you should know these things.
You all are
Christians, or Muslims,
or any other form of religion.
You know nothing about
your own religion?
Maybe you're all pagans, which
would be refreshing, I suppose.
AUDIENCE: He was a Catholic?
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
Ezekiel had a dream.
He was a prophet.
He had a dream that God and
he encountered each other,
and he had instructions
to devise a new temple.
There are six chapters in your
Bible on Ezekiel's dimensions
for this new temple.
Imagine dreaming of a
temple when you're in exile
and designing it in
your mind as a text.
Anyway, strange things happen.
Ezekiel's temple, as I'll
show you in the slides,
has been redrawn and reimagined
from these dimensions
over time.
The Jews return, and
the third significance
of the stay in Babylon,
the Jewish Talmud,
the Book of Laws,
has two versions,
the Palestinian version--
at least the Jerusalem version
and the Babylonian version.
The Babylonian
version is considered
to be the preferred version.
So the Jews in exile
established a culture,
which they brought back to
Jerusalem having been freed,
and Israel read the Bible to
the people for the first time.
And according to
the text, they wept.
So the beginning of
the idea that religion
is a democratic phenomenon
is my explanation
for the problem of Jesus.
I've a rather eccentric
version of the story.
What happened is
we jump 500 years,
and Herod goes and
rebuilds the temple.
He builds an enormous
temple-- bigger than before.
The priests, again,
are in control.
They control power.
They control the
artifact of religion.
They control property.
They control
everything in the city.
Along comes a Jew,
a radical Jew--
has another vision of the world.
Jesus doesn't threaten
the Romans very much.
The Romans are used to dealing
with whatever in the empire,
with infidels.
They just lock them up
or cut their heads off--
very explicit rules.
[INAUDIBLE] in a rather
difficult situation.
The priests are more threatened
by Jesus than other Romans.
The priests, therefore,
connive with the Romans
to execute Jesus.
The notion of
execution of your son
occurs in the Judeo-Christian
Bible before, and although it
wasn't legal, the idea
of passing your son
on as a gift, the use of blood.
22,000 oxen were killed
in the dedication
of the Temple of Solomon.
The whole idea of giving
something to God as a gift--
if you were poor, you brought
a chicken to the temple
to the priest.
If you were wealthy, you
brought a cow, an ox.
If you were very
wealthy, good Lord knows,
you donated your son.
The story of Abraham and
Isaac is that same version
of that gift giving.
The supreme gift is
the gift of your son.
And the Jesus story
is archetypally
the story of God
donating his son, again,
for the improvement
of the world.
Christianity is based on
many mythical stories, which
emanated from the
history of Jerusalem,
and is the second monotheistic
religion to emerge out
of the city.
Muhammad is born in 570 BC.
He fights his battles
in Mecca and Medina,
spreads the idea of Islam as
the third great monotheistic
religion through the
Arabian Peninsula,
and soon afterwards,
Jerusalem is invaded
by the first Arab group.
Significantly, the
Christians had chosen
a site for the great church.
Constantine's mother,
Helena, from Istanbul
or Constantinople,
drifted down to Jerusalem,
and he's supposed to have
selected the site where
Jesus was killed.
On the basis of
that information,
the Church of the Holy
Sepulcher was built
and is still in existence
today, having been destroyed
seven times and rebuilt.
The Arabs arrive in Jerusalem.
They're the newcomers.
They asked the Christian
bishop about sites
for their own mosque.
The Temple Mount, which had been
the site of the Jewish temple,
had been raised by the Romans,
and there was nothing left.
For 500 years, the
Temple Mount was
a rubbish dump of old parts
of buildings and so on.
The Christians wanted
nothing to do with it.
In fact, the Church of the Holy
Sepulcher, which was usually
under the Roman city, entered
from The Cardo on the West,
at least on the
East, was closed.
And you now enter the
Church of the Holy Sepulcher
only from the South.
On the East now, there's
the best candy store
in Jerusalem on The Cardo.
So although the Temple
Mount, which is only two--
to use their phrase--
two-arrow lengths,
bow lengths, away
from the Church of
the Holy Sepulcher,
the Islamic penetrators thought
that the mythological origins
of the use of the Temple
Mount were sufficient for them
to follow the Jewish tradition
of the destroyed temple.
So they rebuilt the Temple
Mount in about 100 years
after Mohammad's birth and
built the two buildings
which are still there today--
The Dome of the Rock
and the Al-Aqsa mosque.
In my writing, I go through
the detailed history
of the idea of resilience,
how under these occupations
each religion plays around
with the idea of permanence.
The Christians in
the Holy Sepulcher
never really agree
on the fundamentals
of the Christian faith.
Whilst they may agree
on the fundamentals,
they don't agree
on its application.
So 70% of the Holy Sepulcher
is still under Greek Christian.
The poor African Ethiopian
Christians live on the roof
and are only allowed to
enter the major tabernacle
by a small staircase.
As one of the writers
writes, "They're
all divided by faith," or
something of this kind.
So you have a notion of the
three major religions having,
in the case of the
Christians, an artifact which
houses divided aspects
of the religion.
There are fires.
They are people killed.
There are all kinds
of disjunctions
between these groups, but
Christianity survives.
On the Islamic front,
you have the church,
the Dome of the Rock, and the
Al-Aqsa mosque, which survive
to this day unblemished.
In 1099, the Crusaders,
under the pressure
from the popes of
Europe, attempt
to restore Christianity.
Instead of dismant--
they are absolutely
ruthless to the degree that they
kill everybody in their sight.
They kill Muslims and Jews.
And in the blood of
their boots, they
walk to the Holy
Sepulcher and pray.
There's always this kind of
interesting biblical thing,
which I focus on also, that
the interpretation of God
is always ambiguous.
God is always punishing people
for doing the wrong things,
but he's also forgiving, if
you come to terms with him--
or her, depending
on what you believe.
So the Crusaders behave in
this apparently bifocal way.
They destroy everybody whom they
see in their sight violently,
and at the same time, they go
and sing hymns in their church.
There may be parallels in
contemporary violence as well.
I don't know if it's a
born-in instinct in humankind,
that you modify your
behavior in two distinct ways
according to your belief system.
The Jews have lost two temples.
They now are in exile.
They take with them books.
That's the only
property they have.
There's writers-- Herschel,
the American Jewish liberal
theological rabbi, Mitchell
[INAUDIBLE] did his PhD
at MIT--
write about the idea
of the Jewish book
as the significant
property of memory.
They argue that,
in fact, they are--
I think it's Herschel that
talks about the Jewish religion
as being a religion of
the architecture of time.
If you look at the layout
of a text in the Mishnah,
you'll see a body of writing.
And on the sides are
Talmudic interpretations
by rabbis over time.
So the truth is never
absolute in this one sense--
that it's always
open to discussion.
It's also that the Jews
took upon themselves--
and Freud himself, who at
one time thought about going
to live in Jerusalem--
says that the Jews
preoccupied themselves
with avoiding pictorial imagery.
You cannot decorate
the synagogue.
The text has to be
absolutely pure.
Jews didn't become architects.
They were never in a
power position in exile
for thousands of years--
well, not thousands of years.
Peter Eisenman and his--
Frank Gehry are Jewish.
And I suppose that we've
made up for that lost time.
But the Jewish
presence after 70 AD
was in exile until the
slow return of the Jews
in the Ottoman period, which
lasted from about 1500 to 1917.
I hope you're following all
of these detailed stories.
But in a sense,
it's only by looking
at the detailed
side of the stories
that you really get a good
idea of the complexity
of the situation.
To say Arab--
I mean, of the 3,000 years
of the history of Jerusalem,
1,200 years would be under
the Israelites or the Jews,
and 1,200 years under
the Arabs or Islam.
Whatever that means, the rest is
divided amongst the Christians
and the Romans.
Jerusalem was, in
the first place,
not a particularly
important city.
It was too steep.
The main circulation
path was to the West
along the Mediterranean.
Jerusalem was the last connector
between the coastal plain
and the endless desert, which
stretched all the way to India.
The Dead Sea close to Jerusalem
was the lowest point on Earth.
So there was-- I'll show
you a slide indicating
this division, geographical
division, on which Jerusalem
sits.
Alexander the Great
visited Jerusalem.
This was an enormous
victory for the Jews.
Many Jews, including my
son, are named Alexander
because of that tradition.
His first name is Peter, but
his second name is Alexander.
I named him after the
Russian giants rather
and Jewish heroes.
So Zionism, as a
phenomenon, occurs in Europe
as a consequence of the
marginalization of Jews
in Central Europe and all the
way to England and France,
the disposition of Jewish land.
The Jews, under
one of the early I
think 12th century English
kings, had to wear labels
marking them as Jews--
the pogroms of Eastern Europe.
I mean, it's a long history
which precedes the Holocaust.
And Jewish reaction to
persecution and punishment
took the form of a biblical
notion of "next year
in Jerusalem."
In the Jewish Passover
service, there
is this phrase, "next
year, in Jerusalem."
The Jewish Passover, unlike
the Christian Easter,
is not dedicated very
much to a religious idea,
but related to the escape
under Moses from Egypt and God
parting the Red Sea to
allow the Jews to escape.
How true that story is, whether
Freud claims that Moses was,
in fact, an Egyptian who
had learned about it.
Well, anyway, there
are too many stories.
When you get all of
these people having
been involved in this
dialogue, on this multilogue,
you have many stories.
The Ottoman Empire chooses to
take the wrong side in the 1418
war, and the British
take over Jerusalem.
They maintain
Jerusalem as a mandate
until 1948, when the
War of Independence
and the Jewish state of Israel
was founded 70 years ago now.
East Jerusalem belongs to
Jordan, West Jerusalem,
to Israel.
1967, there's another war.
This time, the Jews expel
Jordan from East Jerusalem,
and in fact, annex the West
Bank to a united Israel.
The United Nations
proposes that Jerusalem
be an international city.
They actually have a diagram
of the form of Jerusalem
as an international city.
Neither side, neither
Arab nor Jewish politics,
accept that as a resolution.
The Jews start, after the
Oslo Accords, which presumably
sets out that there would be an
independent Palestinian state,
and talks about the
'67 boundary lines
and zones for the future states.
Israel politics, a combination
of religious pressure
and all kinds of other
internal Israeli social issues,
promote the expansion
program, which
now has reached
300,000 settlers living
on land, which is East of the
partition line set by the Oslo
Accords.
Many American presidents,
since Harry Truman I think,
have objected to Israeli
settlement expansion,
with no results whatsoever.
The status quo, at the end of
all of my long story of 3,000
years, is a situation
in which Jerusalem
is claimed by Israel to be
the unique capital of Israel.
Although, as you will
read in my letter,
many of the previous
Israeli presidents
have looked for
alternative sites
to Jerusalem, at least for the
capital of Israel, including
Ben-Gurion's choice of
coordinate in the Negev.
At present, the
Palestinian position
is a slightly more
complex position,
but they would like
to share Jerusalem
as the capital of
their state as well.
So you have a notion, which
I don't think exists anywhere
else in the world,
where one city is
the capital of two countries.
You get St. Louis, Missouri
and St. Louis, Kansas City.
You have divisions in
other parts of the world,
but you have no claim
for a city as being
the capital of two states.
In fact, the notion of two
states is now under discussion.
There's a new,
relatively new, movement,
which argues for the existence
of a single state, which
would alleviate the
problem of the settlements,
but deny Zionist ambitions.
Because demographically,
the Jewish position
is more vulnerable
demographically.
This two-state solution,
which the United States
and most liberal
politicians support,
is for there to be an
independent Palestinian state.
The Palestinians wish to go
back to the 1967 boundary.
They'll have to be
some compromise.
God knows how that
compromise is going
to be worked out between
the size of the settlement
population and the
emaciated, fragmented--
you can see in the last
map in your handout,
just in the case of the
periphery of Jerusalem,
how much this land has become
parcelized and fragmented
rather than unified.
My son's book, which tackles
this problem much more
eloquently than I can, argues
that for a Palestinian state,
which is liberal and not
imposing military law
onto the Palestinians
in the West Bank,
and so on, and so
on, is probably
the most coherent
liberal position
on the subject at the moment.
The future of Jerusalem
may well be never resolved.
It may be the result of too much
history and too much mythology.
Mythology becomes history
at a certain point.
Let me give you an example.
Christians, at Easter today,
celebrate the way of the cross.
They carry the
cross symbolically
from the praetorium
where Jesus was housed
to where he was crucified.
The site of the crucifixion
is not absolutely clear,
but most people now assume it
to be somewhere around where
the sepulcher is.
One of the stations of
the cross, station number
I don't know what--
number seven, I'm
not sure exactly--
it's called the
Ecce Homo station.
That's where the Roman Legion
commander pointed down to Jesus
and said, ecce homo--
look at that man, look at this
man in a derisive manner--
carrying the cross.
In fact, history proves that
to be absolutely nonsense,
but a complete myth.
Archeologists say that the Ecce
Homo Arch was only built long
after Jesus' death and didn't
exist at the time of Jesus.
So the other
conflations of reality,
the Jews are near
the citadel of David
have the site of David's
tomb, above which Christians
claim the Last Supper of Jesus
with his followers took place.
It is now the site of the
Dormitian Abbey, which is
where Mary was supposedly died.
[ITALIAN] Mary--
[ITALIAN] being the
Italian word to sleep--
Dormitian Abbey.
So you have a vertical.
As the history of this
city has grown and layered
upon each other, physically
you have Jewish David
at the bottom.
Jesus is next on top, and
the Ottoman Empire and Mary's
memory on the top.
What do you do about
a place like this?
You fossilize it.
In my letter, in
The New Republic,
I say that it's not
only a religious city.
It's an everyday city in
which people go to school.
People have
transportation problems.
The Jews have just built
a light rail system.
It's a political city.
It never was the capital of any
of the country's Arab countries
that conquered Jerusalem.
I'll show you a
slide of Jerusalem
only being the capital
of the Crusader
empire and the Jewish empire.
What justification that makes
for arguing that Jerusalem
should be the unique capital
of Israel is for you to decide.
This is the most--
I mean, I can give you many
detailed stories and versions
of any of these events.
For instance, in a religious
environment of this kind,
it's amazing how
frequently people
build on the sites of previous
religious institutions.
The Church of the
Holy Sepulcher is
built on the site of the
Roman temple of Aphrodite.
When the Crusaders
capture Jerusalem in 1099,
they go, they march,
to the Dome of the Rock
and the Al-Aqsa mosque.
And instead of
putting them down,
they put a Christian flag on
top of the Dome of the Rock
and called the
Temple of Dominus.
And the Al-Aqsa mosque
becomes Temple Salomonis.
Al-Aqsa mosque has
its foundations
in Solomon's temple stables.
It is constantly-- its
roof is constantly--
its lead roof is constantly
having to be repaired,
because its foundations
are so unstable.
This is the city which is built.
I write in the last
part of my writing
on Louis Kahn's Hurva synagogue.
Well, if you
haven't read it, I'm
not going to tell you the story
of Louis Kahn's interpretation
of how you build in Jerusalem,
his theory of ruins.
So today, the Islam has two
permanent monuments, ways,
people can pray.
The Jews don't have any.
They pray in the open air.
The holiest presence
is in the Western Wall,
which is eroding in ancestry.
And the Christians still have
the desecrated holy place
of the Sepulcher,
Christ's passion--
the location of
Christ's passion.
And such is an abbreviated
story of Jerusalem.
Now, what do you do?
I worked for the
Palestinian side.
I worked not for the
Israeli government,
but for the mayor of
Jerusalem over time.
So my investment in this
city is more than just
knowing its history, which
I only know partially.
The history of religion
is so extensive
that to understand it all--
I don't even understand
who Gabriel was.
The figure is in
some story somewhere.
I mean, the books
about the Last Supper,
which talk about the
tradition of eating together
and what that means, the
book's about the killing
of your first son--
remember the one of the plagues
that the Egyptians or God cast
on the Egyptians for the
persecution of the Jews
was the killing
of the first son.
That's why the baby Moses
was hidden in the reeds.
We can go on and on,
and on and on, and on.
Religion is a business which
produces lots of myths,
and realities, and
interpretations to keep
itself going.
OK, we should look at
some of these pictures
so you get a better idea of
what this place looks like.
The options are simple.
This is the present Israeli
option for Jerusalem.
If this is Palestine
and this is Israel,
Jerusalem has a secure
border on its East side.
This is a metropolitan
city, as indicated
in the drawing of the
Palestinian planner
with the central.
The problem of what happens
on a boundary between two
countries in terms of
security and customs
isn't answered by one.
You have to dispense with it.
You can only dispense
with that if you
have secure relationship.
The European Union has
dispensed with passports
by virtue of an assumption
that there is no reason
to maintain fortified borders
any longer between France
and Belgium, for instance.
But can you conceive of this
being a solution in relation
to two pretty hostile entities?
How are you going to deal with
security in a unified city--
small details?
The historic site has--
if an Iraqi wishes to
visit the Dome of the Rock,
he or she has to penetrate
some kind of a line,
or presumably
there is line which
has to be penetrated at all.
This is a position
where Palestine
encircles Jerusalem in the
counterpoint to this proposal.
Are there any other
possibilities?
What do you think
at the back there?
AUDIENCE: Possibility for what?
JULIAN BEINART: Hmm?
JULIAN BEINART: For the
future of Jerusalem,
given either one or--
given a one-state solution,
there's no problem.
It's the capital
of a single state.
But if it's the--
another solution is a
version of number 1--
that the Ramallah, the United
States, and the European Union
give a billion dollars
to the Palestinians
to build a new capital.
AUDIENCE: It's not a question
of where other people want
them to put the capital.
[INAUDIBLE] for Israel the same.
There's two sides of Jerusalem.
JULIAN BEINART: I understand.
AUDIENCE: There is a
place to divide it.
There is a divide, without there
being a political division.
There is a community
that's divided.
The problem is that it's
the issue of security
and whether everybody from--
what the Palestinians
can control
who comes right up to the
edge of the Israeli side
or the Jewish side.
That's the problem.
JULIAN BEINART: I understand.
What I'm concluding is
that there is no solution
and that this will just
perpetuate itself in history,
causing bloodshed as blood
accompanies this history
of Jerusalem for
2,000, 3,000 years.
That it'll just continue to be--
it is too intoxicated a site
by the virtue of the three
major religions in the world.
Forgive me if I
leave the others out.
And to use Aldo Rossi's
term, "The locus
is such that it
is irresolvable."
It's a bleak future for
both Palestine and Israel.
Maybe there's a solution which
doesn't include Jerusalem.
This is the one which
I'm indicating here,
where East Jerusalem is a
suburb of another state,
of a city in another
state, but that's
a far-fetched resolution.
There's the West
versus the East,
the countries of Palestine
versus Israel, the race Arab
versus Hebrew, language Hebrew
versus Arabic, religion Islam
and Christianity versus
Judaism, Israel's relationship
with the West, with
Palestine's association
with the Middle East
and the Arab world,
Israel's preoccupation with
Western and industrial growth,
Palestine's developing
economy in agriculture
and in technical industry,
the Jewish background
of the Holocaust and the
Arab treatment of Jews
in Arab countries, Palestine's
heritage of colonialism,
exploitation, and so on, and
so on, and so on, and so on.
You just travel the
world of imagery.
It's cheaper.
Jerusalem, like so many parts
of this world, [INAUDIBLE]
is exactly the same,
topological structure.
It's built on folded
plains causing
valleys, and hillsides, and
different kinds of notions
of development.
This is a more or less
contemporary imagery.
This is the old city here.
This is the mosque,
Al-Aqsa mosque, and that's
the Dome of the Rock.
This is the Western Wall.
This is Jewish expansion
from the 19th century onward,
westward, Beit HaKarem,
and all the way
to the Jewish Israeli museum,
the Jewish capital parliament
buildings, and
further westwards.
Next.
Jerusalem lying on watershed
between the coastal plain
on the West and the endless
desert on the right.
Next.
David's building of
the city on the south.
The city was always
defensible on the south
more easily than it
was in the north.
The Romans invaded
from the north.
This is a set of reconstruction
of Solomon's Temple
over the centuries.
Next.
Corbusier's sketch of
the Holy of the Holies
under the nomadic tent.
The whole idea of the
temple is creating
an audience of people in the
community in the foreground,
but no penetration of
the building itself.
Jesus inherits temple.
He said to exonerate--
not attacked,
but assaulted the sellers
of goods in the foreground
of the temple.
At a certain point
he says, the temple
will be destroyed
after my death.
He says to his associates,
from then onwards,
you won't need a temple.
My body will be your temple.
Here, you have a
religious substitution
of the image of
the body, the mass.
In Catholicism, the use of
the wafer to eat something
refers to the actual consumption
of the symbolic consumption
of a body.
The wine stands for blood.
These primitive and
primeval relationships.
Next.
God is the architect.
Augustine, on the
right, is seeing God,
envisioning a second
city up in the sky.
For Jews, it was the second--
the ethereal Jerusalem
is about 10 miles up.
For Arabs, it's
about 15 miles up.
Next.
Reversionary construction
of these Ezekiel's temple
from the six, seven chapters.
I didn't go into
this, and I think
we'll leave it for the moment.
It was the notion of
the invention of heaven.
For the Jews, it
seemed to me that early
on the God with Yahweh,
heaven was above,
but dead human beings were
not part of the territory that
should be taken account of.
Priests wore gloves when
dealing with dead human beings,
like animals.
Next.
Here, it's temple
reconstruction.
The great battle, the
invasion, of the Romans
and the slaughter of the Jews.
Next.
The only map of Jerusalem,
this is in Jordan
in a place called
Madaba, near Aman.
This is a mosaic floor in
a church in Madaba showing
the Roman construction of
The Cardo, The East-West
Cardo, and the Decumanus
from the Jaffa Gate
running right angles.
Next.
This is the Ecce Homo Arch.
We're looking at
a map of Jerusalem
at the time of the
death of Christ.
You will see the connection
from the praetorium.
So here, it's praetorium at
the top of the Temple Mount
diagram along the way of the
cross, all the way to Golgotha,
to the Golgotha hill, and the
putative passion of Christ.
This is [INAUDIBLE],,
this way of the cross
is a ritualistic
celebration carried out
each Easter in Jerusalem
by thousands of pilgrims
from all over the world.
Next.
The temple of Aphrodite
prior to the establishment
of the church.
The original establishment
of the Church of the Holy
Sepulcher has various
religious components,
but it connects to The
Cardo on the extreme right.
Next.
Here is a version of it
after the Arab presence.
The entrance now is
on the south here,
and its connection to The
Cardo is truncated and stopped.
These are various components
of the Christian story.
Next.
The Christian faiths
do not trust access
to the Church of
the Holy Sepulcher,
and for centuries have
endured the Nusaybah family,
an Israeli Islamic
family, with the keys.
Here is the entrance
to the south.
Next.
Here's the roof.
A Christian priest living
on the roof of the Church
of the Holy Sepulcher
in semi-exile, and here
is an Easter night
celebration on the roof.
Next.
The establishment,
first establishment,
of the Dome of the Rock, the
circular purple building,
and the Al-Aqsa
mosque on the south,
and the many
institutions leaving
this part of the holy city
to be the Jewish quarter.
The Basilica of Holy Zion--
slowly there's something
about the Armenian quarter
and the Christian quarter to
develop further to the north.
Next.
The Dome of the Rock,
that Al-Aqsa mosque--
next.
The Crusader period for
a relatively short time,
the [LATIN],, the baptistery,
the Temple Salomonis,
the previous Al-Aqsa mosque,
not destroyed but maintained,
only Christianized
in a simple way--
all the Christian
institutions which
grow up under the Crusader.
St. James Cathedral, the Greek
hopice, the Syrian monastery,
the church of St. Martin,
St. John the Baptist,
the Hospitaliers
quarter, the building
of the largest
hospital in the world
at that time in the
Muristan district,
largely part of the
Christianic beneficence.
Next.
The retaking of the city under
Arab Islamic circumstances
by Saladin, rebuilding
of the walls,
the wall's rebuilt in 1131,
1191 to 1213, all of the schools
and community places as a
result of the Islamicization
of this space.
1917, Jerusalem prior, at the
time of the British invasion.
Next.
I mentioned the example
of the [INAUDIBLE],,
the layering of David's
tomb, the Dormitian Abbey,
and the [INAUDIBLE]
Caiaphas, one of the agents
in the death of Jesus.
But the Last Supper takes
place there as well.
Here is the Dormitian
Abbey, which
has these three layers of
vertical space belonging
to different religions.
Next.
The final subdivision of the
Holy City into four sectors,
the Dome of the Rock,
and the Al-Aqsa mosque,
penetrating into the Jewish
sector with the Dung Gate.
That's this gate.
The Golden Gate, which
is not open any longer
to the Islamic
section, which has
the Damascus Gate on the
north as its major entrance.
The Church of the
Holy Sepulcher,
and the Christian sector,
and the Armenian sector here.
The Jaffa Gate leads to--
is the prime-- if you
extend these lines,
the Jaffa Gate extends
to the Mediterranean.
The Dung Gate extends
down to Egypt.
The Damascus Gate
extends upwards to Syria,
and this closed Golden Gate
potentially extends eastwards
to Iraq.
Next.
The contemporary
city on the left,
the coexistence of
tall skyscrapers
on the west in the Jewish city.
Next.
The British occupation,
the McLean Plan,
it's not very clear,
but it's an attempt
to recognize the western part,
the Jewish part, and developing
it according to a
garden city model.
The Arab side is left gray for
reasons I don't understand.
Restricted building
and open space--
extraordinary plan.
And the United Nations' plan,
which encloses a larger area
than the municipality, and it
encloses Bethlehem [INAUDIBLE]
on the east, including Hadassah
Hospital and Hebrew University
on the northeast--
rejected by both sides.
Next.
Jerusalem's rulers from 587--
that's Nebuchadnezzar
and Babylon to 1967 AD--
showing that Jerusalem had
consequence at a distance.
The 1967 dividing of the
city in the east and west
with a boundary between the two.
Next.
The boundary taken over
and a map showing--
map by protagonists
of the Arab cause,
arguing that the
Jews have always
tried to locate settlements in
a pattern which causes the city
not to be unified.
Next.
Louis Kahn's-- one of the
Louis Kahn's great buildings,
which he never built, and his
very interesting interpretation
of the use of ruins
in a city of--
could you just turn on
those lights, please?
When you have the intersection
of religion, politics,
geography, and history,
you cannot do anything.
It's frozen.
I don't know of a situation
which has managed to overcome--
maybe Belgian.
I suppose in Europe at
least the elimination
of obstacles towards
the creation of a plane
of general acceptance.
And the European
Union is perhaps
the most modern example of
the breaking down of barriers.
The barriers are still
between Algiers and Paris.
It's between the hinterland
of countries, Turkey
and the European Union, sending
migrant labor back and forth.
But this is a
phenomenon which is not
easily applied to Jerusalem.
In the case of
Johannesburg, you will
see the absence of religion.
It is purely a question of race.
Once you eliminate region
and you only deal with race,
you find it easier to resolve,
even although South Africa
has struggled into the
post-apartheid democracy.
It took enormous resources,
and time, and bloodshed.
And Johannesburg is an
artifact of race, and so on.
So we look at these others
in a slightly different light
than Jerusalem.
But Jerusalem is the great
metaphysical city of the world.
It's the most important
metaphysical presence.
What that means, meaning-wise,
is difficult to say.
They are parts where you tread
and walk softly and slowly,
because you have a
history of associations
with that particular place.
And these associations
are carefully vivid.
There have been
Palestinian riots
around the archaeology
of certain regions
in the olden city.
Somebody one day will try to
excavate under the Holy Mount
to see if the Holies
of Holy is still there.
Steven Spielberg's probably
likely to do the movie.
Although, he's done a
movie which is similar.
Anyway, any thoughts
about all of this?
Complexity is an easy evasion.
You know, wherever I go around
the world hearing people talk
about cities, the
modern interpretation
is they're too complex to
have theories about them.
And no city is more
complex than Jerusalem.
No city has been the site
of three major religions.
of 3,000 years of invasion
and succession, resilience
and the building
up of history and myths.
You should go and visit it.
That's all I can recommend.
See if you can make
any sense of it.
You've lived in
Jerusalem, haven't you?
AUDIENCE: I never
lived in Jerusalem.
JULIAN BEINART: You never--
AUDIENCE: I've been
there hundreds of times,
but never [INAUDIBLE]
for more than one night.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
The first immigrant
Zionists saw Jerusalem
as an old-fashioned
historically-bound city.
And [INAUDIBLE] chose to
make Tel Aviv the capital,
or Haifa the capital
facing the Mediterranean,
or in the case of Ben-Gurion,
the new city of [INAUDIBLE]..
It's Chaim Weizmann
who found Jerusalem
to be archaic and medieval, and
the new Jewish Zionist spirit
was in favor of novelty
and social equity, and some
of the things which it hasn't
been able to perpetuate.
OK, we'll do
Johannesburg on Thursday
and see if there's
any comparison.